hello everyone and welcome to another
very enjoyable game uh from round two of
this year's norway chess it's magnus
cross and versus sari antares so an all
out norwegian clash uh and uh well like
i said this is the armageddon the
classical game ended in a draw i was it
was um the kind of intense magnus to
give up the queen for two rooks and uh
then in the end it just all ended in a
draw uh it was um
could have gone uh maybe in magnus's
favor but could have also gone in
black's favor i guess so
nothing really going on there uh but
this is now armageddon seven minutes for
magnus he has to win aryan has 10
minutes and he has to hold to a draw to
win the match so let's see how this goes
as we'll have a new game already as of
move 7 which is very very cool as this
is the the joko pianissimo uh so magnus
with the white pieces opens with e4 with
e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop
to c4
magnus goes for the italian game knight
to f6 the two knights defense and now d3
and we have bishop to c5 now we're in
the joko pianissimo uh and c3 now
preparing to advance on the queen side
but also uh this will support the
advancement of the d4 pawn at some point
so d6 preparing to develop the the light
square bishop and now knight b to d2 we
have a5 by tari
a6 is what uh you usually play here a5
comes with a bit of a different idea you
don't take away the b5 square from the
light square bishop but then again you
prevent the whites expansion on the
queen side with a4 b for b5 and so on
which
makes it easier for white to claim the
center and here magnus could just castle
but he starts with knight to f1
uh he's not worried about any threats
here and he just wants to reposition the
knight to g3 then to f5 maybe and so on
and black doesn't really gain anything
by going to g4 right away going for that
f2 pawn it doesn't seem like it's easily
defended but you can just play d4 and
it's perfectly fine for white for
example captures capture so we can
deliver a check bishop to d2 and
everything is nicely defended so instead
after this knight to f1 uh there are uh
some games where bishop to g4 was played
also castles is a known move but bishop
to e6 in this position the move that
toddy plays is a new move so like i said
already as of move seven we have a
completely new game so magnus says all
right you played a5 you don't have
control of a6 i'm going to put my bishop
on b5 uh
pin your knight and now the knight is uh
not uh well uh
the the knight doesn't have any control
of the center for the moment so here we
have castles now the knight does uh gain
control of the center once again and now
knight the g3 so now magnus is ready to
castle and now knight to e7 not allowing
this capture to happen to the double
black spawns
and now d4 so it was only a matter of
time before white um executes this pawn
advancement with e capture sunday for c
captures and bishop to b for check
and now what do you play here well you
could defend with something like bishop
to d2 but that is not how we play chess
nowadays in the true spirit of modern
chess magnus plays king to f1 also known
as the new castles and now he might have
some ideas of maybe pushing the h pawn
maybe bringing the rook into the game
via via the uh
h file uh we'll see what happens uh we
have c6 pushing the bishop back bishop
back to d3 and now uh a4 preparing a
three to
a weak and wide skiing side
sorry queen side and now a3 attacking
the bishop here uh but now tari doesn't
move the bishop because where do you
move the bishop if you move it here
we're just gonna win the a4 pawn so here
bishop to b3 his bishop pair is very
very nicely placed here but it's only
temporarily so bishop to c2 what do you
play here toddy captures we have
characters captures and now again
this bishop doesn't have a good square
you have to move it somewhere and the a5
square is the only square available but
that also means giving up the a4 pawn so
magnus grabs it and now there are no
good discoveries there's no square you
can move the bishop to make use of this
uh
uh rook eyeing that queen so here we
have d5 carlton's king is still on f1 so
he is up upon but unless that rook joins
the game uh it's it's still black who
should be favored here at least in uh
in a such a uh well uh short time
control we have e5 keeping the center
closed knight to e4 and now queen back
to c2 ready to pick up the knight here
uh and here tari plays f5 he really
wants to open up lines uh towards that
white king knights the e2 now
and here we have f4 this is very very
interesting uh as uh tari has the black
pieces he only needs a draw uh to win
the match in in the armageddon but he's
pushing everything forward so here
magnus says all right i will take that
pawn i don't mind the df file opening up
and knight the g6 now attacking the
bishop and also that knight is coming to
h4 you want to trade this knight for the
f3 knight and then the queen will have
access to white's king's side so bishop
back to e3 and now knight to h4
so now of course uh you could capture
here but this just gives the black too
much look at all this pressure along the
f file uh black can easily double up on
the f file and it's gonna be it's gonna
be ugly so after knight to h4 magnus
just continues with knight to g3 he says
you can have this knight and the pawn if
you want it's not a problem and indeed
it is not a problem for example if
knight captures g captures which was
played in the game had tarry continued
with rook captures on f3
magnus wants to play king to g2 and he
would very much enjoy giving up this
pawn to get the rook into the game for
example if queen to f8 we can just play
queen e2 and now this rook has to move
once the rook moves we're going to play
f3 kick away the knight and now the
knight could go back you could capture
on g3 but again it's white who's better
there's no pressure along the f file the
queen and king do a fine job defending
everything and you can even double up
here on the h file uh while black's
bishop uh will have a very hard time of
entering the game there there really is
no way for this bishop to enter the game
uh with white's a very strong center
here at some point you will have to play
c5 to break open the center uh but that
requires a few moves so instead after g
captures on f3 tali doesn't go for the
pawn he plays knight to g5 now he has
ideas of knight captures on f3 and now
f4
attacking the knight the knight the
opponent is now nicely defended here
knight to f3 and now you could go for
king to g2 but uh then knight h4 check
might uh come in handy to black
uh so magnus plays h4 advances this pawn
uh and takes away the h4 square from the
black knight and now king to g2 is
definitely playable uh and targos c5
it's time to bust open the center here
and he has to do something so he has to
give up uh more pawns uh in order to
open up this and magnus could capture
with this with the d-pawn he could
capture with the queen but he says i
have plenty of cons i don't want to you
know over grab any pawns so here we are
king the g2 preparing to bring the rook
into the game now comes knight captures
on d4 we have bishop captures c captures
now that he has a very nice pass to deep
on and well two a doubled fast d pawn uh
and magnus says not a problem i'm just
gonna advance this pawn to f5 now magnus
has a past e pawn and you always have to
be careful either this pawn is coming to
e6 or or this pawn is coming to f6 so
here we have queen to e8 uh attacking
this pawn but uh not problem magnus just
plays b4 challenges the bishop here
bishop to b6 uh and now rook h to e1
defending
made possible by the queen leaving this
diagonal the h for pawn is no longer
hanging so rook h to e1
definitely makes sense we rook the c8
bringing the rook into the game with
tempo attacking the queen and now queen
to b3 now putting pressure on this on
this pawn uh so ideas like rook to c3
are not yet possible uh the d5 pawn will
fall so here we have rook to c4 but now
again queen to f3 again going for the
spawn and this time with with an even
greater threat so queen to c6 defending
but now uh the uh well black's defense
has kind of left that king side and now
magnus is ready to start pushing now
it's a question do you want to push the
e pawn or do you want to push the f pawn
uh since this is a must-win game and the
time on the clock is low
magnus plays f6 if this was a classical
game surely e6 would come and then e7
and then we would see something in those
lines but here we have f6
and now how can black defend for the
moment white can't really capture
anything as the queen is also on the f
file so queen to e6 and now comes knight
to f5 threatening to pick up the g7 pawn
and the capturing here just results uh
in in game over for black just queen g4
checked king f7 queen here checking
would have to go here and now he
captures an f6 that's it there's there's
no defending this so after knight to f5
we have g6 by tari and now knight to e7
with check uh going after that d5 pawn
uh it's not a lot but it's uh it's
enough king to h8 knight captures on d5
now attacking the bishop here and tari
now plays d3 uh the idea being that uh
if the queen captures this pass pawn
sorry about the wrong arrows uh we would
have something like rook to g for check
and you might have some problems here
for example king f1 bishop to d4 now
you've disconnected the queen's defense
of the knight also the rook is attacked
so black is definitely back in the game
so instead after d3 magnus just
eliminates one of toddy's attackers uh
and now
uh should should the knight be captured
right away just e6 and that's it there's
no defense against this so instead after
knight captures on v6 we have rook to g4
with check king to f1 and now even d2
attacking carlson's rook here but it
just rooked to e3 saying that okay you
can you can have your knight i'm just
going to continue pushing my pawns so
rook to d for now
saying that uh well now i'm giving you a
chance to save your knight but if you do
this for example knight to a4 then you
might run in some like queen to c for
check king to g1 rogue g4 check then
we're gonna pick up the h4 pawn again
with check so it could be a little bit
messy white should be okay but it's
armageddon you don't want to
uh you don't want to try you know too
much so after rook to d4 we have rook to
d1 keeping it simple and now toddy has
nothing better than to capture this
knight so queen captures on b6 and of
course magnus just advances his pawn we
have e6 and now queen to b5 with check
we have rook to e2
and now what do you play well toddy
tried rook to d3 attacking white's queen
but white's position is simply much much
better a lot of moves are possible here
for white but uh you know we always look
for that absolute best one that absolute
quickest way to win so feel free to
pause the video and try to find this
quickest way to win for magnus while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on well you could
move the queen that's perfectly fine
queen queen f4 queen e4 that works but
we always look for that absolute the
quickest way so for those of you who
found it congratulations uh you are an
excellent spotter of the quickest way to
win the move is e7 i know it seems uh
fairly simple but you know you always
have to make sure that it really works
uh and now what do you do here well rook
to e8 of course if we capture the queen
then just capture zero with checkmate or
we don't even have to bring a queen we
even bringing the rook into the game is
enough uh since the pawn covers the g7
square so uh it all ends in checkmate so
here we have rook to e8 and now i know
you guys really want to push f7 but f7
would be a mistake here uh it's okay to
play with style just not too much style
if we play f7 now then the problem is we
can just capture the queen and now this
f8 square is defended twice so you're
not bringing your queen into the game
and if you capture here the queen guards
uh the d8 square so you will not be uh
you know enjoying uh
a new queen anytime soon white is still
okay he does have two rooks and he will
have this pawn on e7 remaining uh but
there would be a way to ruin this game
uh so instead after rook to e8 now you
have to play a slow move queen to e4 was
played just getting the queen out of
danger now f7 is unstoppable so queen to
d7 by tardy trying to start some trouble
with queen to h3 check but just f7
there's no defense against this whatever
we play doesn't really matter
so queen to h3 check king the g1 and it
was in this position on mu 47 that
arientari resigned in the game and
another very nice victory for magnus
carlsen in round two of the norway chess
2021 uh in armageddon so he doesn't get
the full three points but he gets a
point for a draw and another half a
point for uh for winning the armageddon
uh and here you resign because there's
no continuation whatever you play of
course you can see that everything is uh
hanging even ideas like a queen to e5
checkmate are in the air so
there's absolutely nothing to try here
you could you know try some like rook
the g3 check captures captures rook to
g2
but that's it there's no continuing this
it would be it would be it would be
pointless of course ari knows this and
after king g1 he resigned the game
uh so
that's the the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh very nice all out
norwegian clash uh i would like to thank
uh f lightheart suhaz rajya chandra
gupta uh leave you han uh jeff langley
and samuel camulli for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day